[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update on
the coolest developer news from
Google and our 150th episode
of "The Dev Show," "TL;DR."
Android Q beta 1 is now
available for early adopters,
and a preview SDK is
available for developers.
It brings a number of
additional privacy and security
features for users, as well
as enhancements for foldables,
new APIs for connectivity,
new media codecs and camera
capabilities and NNAPI
extensions, Vulcan 1.1 support,
faster app startup, and more.
To learn more, head on
over to this extensive post
linked in the description below.
Android app bundles and
Google Play's dynamic delivery
introduce modular
development, reduce app size,
and streamline the
release process.
We recently announced
some new improvements
based on your
suggestions, including
a new API for installing
additional languages,
a streamlined publishing
process for Instant-enabled app
bundles, a new enrollment option
for app signing by Google Play,
and more.
Details and examples
are on the post.
The stable release of the
Android Jetpack navigation
component is now available.
Its suite of libraries,
tooling, and guidance
provides a complete
navigation framework,
freeing you from the challenges
of implementing navigation
yourself.
A video and links to
resources are on the post.
Last week at the Game Developers
Conference in San Francisco,
we announced Firebase
Crashlytics for Unity,
open sourcing our C++ SDK,
new AI-assisted monkey actions
for games on Android, and
support for Game Center
authentication on iOS.
Screenshots and links
are on the post.
With the Google Maps
platform for gaming,
we use the power
of Google Maps and
our real-time global
understanding of the world
to take mobile gaming
to the next level.
We're making new features
available to build gameplay
that's even more contextualized
and more engaging,
including biome,
elevation, and pathfinding.
Example videos are on the post.
Site reliability engineering
uses prescriptive methods
and principles for building
and running reliable systems,
and there's a new
Coursera course
that's dedicated to helping
you get started with SRE.
It's called Site Reliability
Engineering, Measuring
and Managing Reliability.
A link to the course
is on the post.
We recently announced a
new open source project,
the Accessibility
Scanner for iOS.
It's a developer tool that can
assist in locating and fixing
accessibility issues while
an app is being developed.
A link to the GitHub
repo is on the post.
In Chrome 73, we added support
for creating portable content
with signed HTTP
exchanges, dynamically
changing styles with
constructable style sheets,
support for PWAs on
Mac, and a lot more.
For all the updates,
take a look at the post.
Also, Chrome 74 beta
is now available,
reducing unwanted motion,
introducing private class
fields, and a new
feature policy API.
Lots more detail on
that post as well linked
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
I'm going to break
something, I think.
Hope not.